jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen zu
meinem heutigen video es kam mir schon
länger wieder keine videos auf meinem
kanal weil gleich voll bin aber ich habe
mir derzeit einige gedanken über das
youtuber sein gemacht ich glaube wir
sind es alle insgesamt ziemlich einig
dass youtuber sein cooles und dass man
extrem privilegiert ist sowas machen zu
dürfen und damit auch geld zu verdienen
aber ich dachte mir ich zähle euch jetzt
mal die fünf schönsten youtube momente
auf die ich so hatte wir sind jetzt fünf
sache an die ich mich erinnere mit
sicherheit gab es auch noch andere
sachen die ich wirklich cool fand aber
die ich jetzt einfach nicht auf dem
schirm hatte beginnen wir mal ich weiß
noch ganz genau als ich kurz davor stand
meine 100.000 abonnenten zu erreichen
das war ganz genau ein jahr nachdem ich
youtube angefangen hatte ja was soll ich
sagen ich wahrheit also wirklich ich
fand es einfach mega 100.000 abonnenten
ich weiß noch ganz genau ich bin am
abend schlafen gegangen habe meine ganze
familie gesagt wahrscheinlich werde ich
wenn ich morgen früh aufstehe 100.000
abonnenten haben weil ich bin als
schlafen gegangen
das waren 99 1998 oder so und dann war
ich relativ klar dass ich am nächsten
morgen die 100000 haben würde zu und
dann bin ich aufgewacht habe gecheckt
und gesehen 100.000 abonnenten das war
schon der hammer ist ich habe mich mega
gefreut allein über diese tatsache dass
sich 100.000 abonnenten hatte und da bin
ich runtergegangen zum frühstückstisch
oder hatte einfach meine mum ihren
zettel hingelegt weiter herr max
herzlichen glückwunsch 2000 abonnenten
und hatte wie ein kuchen gebacken und
das fand ich so cool also wirklich so
meine mom hat mich nicht versteht nicht
viel von diesem ganzen youtube bing aber
die fahren einfach ich fand's einfach
schön ich meine
irgendwie hat es ausgedrückt dass sie
schon stolz darauf ist und man ist es
immer schön wenn die familie
insbesondere die eltern stolz auf einen
sind und das hat das zu einem sehr
besonderen moment gemacht einmal dass
mich so viele leute abonniert haben und
dass sich so viele leute irgendwie
begeistert habe und andererseits was
meine mama
so eine liebe aktion gebracht hat nur
zwei meiner liste die sind irgendwie
nicht in der reihenfolge übrigens als
sie erfahren habe dass ich bei wago
dabei bin beim ersten und die erste
aufnahme ich habe selbst bevor ich mit
youtube angefangen habe eine kurze zeit
minecraft youtube angeschaut und habe
halt immer diese großen projekte
bewundert und sobald ich dann selbst
youtuber war habe ich mich irgendwie
gedacht irgendwann will ich da mal
mitmachen und ich hatte echt immer wenn
es irgendwo hakt probiert irgendwie reis
zu kommen und dann hat luca grüße gehen
raus für mich klar gemacht dass ich bei
war ein kann und mein gott ich war heiß
ja dann die erste wahre aufnahme gehört
ja noch so ein bisschen dazu mega
spannend und es hat sich einfach
angefühlt als keine angst ist einfach
nur mal ein komplett anderes gefühl so
dieses so zuspiel als normal zu stehen
das war schon echt cool nummer drei die
ersten fan begegnungen beziehungsweise
video days und fantreffen und sonst was
bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo man die leute
wirklich trifft die die eigenen videos
anschauen sind zahlen zahlen palette
kommentare aber vor allem sind ist
einfach zahlen die man wachsen sieht die
ersten begegnungen mit mit zuschauern
mit fans waren einfach ziemlich krass
weiß auch wie wenig ich das am anfang
glauben wollte als leute mich so
angesprochen haben und fotos oder
autogramm oder sonstwas wollten weil ich
mein bis zu dem zeitpunkt wo ich zum
ersten mal angesprochen wurde peilt
zumindest wenn ich draußen unterwegs war
ganz normal das klingt jetzt krass aber
ich habe mich halt so gefühlt wie du
oder du oder du oder du dich fühlen
würdest wenn irgendjemand dich nach
einem autogramm gefragt und das war
irgendwie echt krass aber ich meine so
die ersten video days da hat das einfach
so cool einfach die ganzen leute zusehen
geschenke zu bekommen und gesagt zu
bekommen was man teilweise schon im
leben von manchen leuten bewirkt hat
einfach dadurch dass man youtube videos
machen sie unterhält das hat mich auf
jeden fall echt glücklich gemacht
das war schön ich weiß man auch als ich
vor allem minecraft videos gemacht hatte
und irgendwie so ein tiefpunkt erreicht
hatte so vom gefühl her irgendwie diese
ganze änderungen auf youtube so hin zum
klick welt hin und sonst was war also
voll im gange und ich konnte mich
einfach nicht damit identifizieren und
da habe ich einfach ein video gemacht wo
ich einfach so mir alles
der seele geredet habe sage ich mal und
dieses video hat so schnell so viele
likes bekommen es hat nicht mehr viele
aufrufe bekommen aber es hat so viele
likes bekommen und so unheimlich viele
unterstützende kommentare also ich weiß
noch ganz genau ich habe mich damals ich
saß vor dem handy und ab aktualisiert
aktualisiert aktualisiert weil ich
einfach recht einfach unglaublich cool
fanden so wie viel rückhalt man
eigentlich geboten bekommt durch als
community wenn man mal irgendwie eine
schlechtere zeit hat und weil ich ein
gutes gefühl damals irgendwie habe ich
mich so ein bisschen verstanden gefühlt
man mittlerweile geht es nicht mehr ohne
irgendwie selbst zu klick beten oder
sonst was aber damals hatte ich halt
dafür gekämpft dass man die leute
zurückdrängt die das quasi eingeführt
haben sag ich mal
ja und die letzte sache die mich
ziemlich rwe gemacht hat hat sich jetzt
letztens ereignet ich meine klar ist als
youtube verdient man geld und eine sache
die man mit geld machen kann ist zum
beispiel sich eine wohnung mieten und ja
ich hab jetzt tatsächlich in köln eine
wohnung bekommen und das coole ist ich
hab dann haufen youtuber in meiner
direkten nähe die ich wirklich gerne mag
und auch ein wenig schon besonders lange
kenne
auf jeden fall ist es einfach immer
wieder krass zu merken wie privilegiert
man auch in finanzieller hinsicht durch
youtube ist weil im prinzip macht mir
das spaß was ich hier gerade mache und
wie man dafür finanziell belohnt wird
ist einfach traumhaft wie soll ich sagen
auch wenn geld immer so ein kleines
verbot thema auf youtube ist ist es
einfach cool
auch dafür bin ich dankbar ja leute ich
hab jetzt einfach ein bisschen frei
geredet über sachen die ich gut fand ich
hoffe mal das video durch gefallen mir
persönlich hat eine menge spaß gemacht
das alles mal revue passieren zu lassen
in meinem kopf diese ganzen schönen
momente dabei von minecraft bahro freut
euch darauf wenn ich mich selbst nicht
gut genug kennen würde dann würde ich
jetzt sagen dass wir öfter videos kommen
und bis zum nächsten mal tschüss